Guttenberg Airport in Sweden it was from
here in July 2018 that a Turkish
Airlines aircraft was scheduled to
depart for Istanbul on board a rejected
asylum seeker being deported to
Afghanistan and Swedish student Ellen
Arsen seeking to stop the flight she
broadcast her mission live from her
smartphone that's an ignored numerous
request to take a seat until the pilot
agreed to let the asylum seeker off the
plane the video was viewed millions of
times across the Internet
Nelson was celebrated by some as a hero
of civil disobedience but she also faced
a torrent of abuse
[Applause]
Elson was charged with violating
Sweden's aviation act for refusing to
comply with instructions
her lawyer contested the allegation
saying the instructions had come from
the crew rather than the pilot national
laws defined the crimes that can be
prosecuted it is clear that what
happened on July 23 did not violate any
specific law so there was no punishable
offence arson faced up to six months in
jail instead judges handed down a fine
totaling 370 euros